et j'ouvre notre second débat tout de
suite vous le savez on cherche à le le
décaler le plus souvent possible de
l'actualité du jour il nous emmène ce
soir en Inde l'année prochaine le pays
deviendra le plus peuplé au monde avec
1,4 milliards d'habitants c'est aussi
l'économie mondiale avec la croissance
la plus florissante mais qui en profite
vraiment le Premier ministre voulait en
faire la nouvelle usine du monde a-t-il
réussi à vendre nos experts sur ce thème
on compare l'un des sons puissants
voisins chinois avec Quentin Calmet
septembre 2022 apple présente le dernier
modèle de son téléphone star avec une
nouveauté de taille cet iPhone haut de
gamme sera produit en Inde la première
fois que la fabrication d'une nouvelle
génération de smartphones est fabriqué
hors de Chine et un symbole pour le
sous-continent l'Inde devrait connaître
en 2022 le plus fort taux de croissance
au monde à 6,8% selon le FMI le pays
connaît un rythme deux fois supérieur à
la moyenne des autres pays des
performances qui font rêver et pourquoi
pas doubler un jour son voisin chinois
là c'est
redémarreienne effectivement après les
fait covid encore une fois
c'est deux fois plus que la Chine en
2002 c'est évidemment c'est historique
malgré tout on reste sur une base de
départ qui est par la même si on compare
avec la Chine le PIB chinois est plus de
cinq fois supérieur au pays bel indien
l'Inde profite aussi du relatif des
engagements des industriels en Chine le
pays est empêtré dans la sanitaire de sa
stratégie zéro covid ces derniers mois
les investisseurs se sont désengagés des
marchés chinois en partie au profit de
son voisin indien pour autant les défis
à relever restent immense pour le pays
ça reste un pays qui est encore une
partie de la population qui est pauvre
extrêmement pauvre
l'indice multidestionne
multidimensionnel de pauvreté en Inde
place ce pays au 132e rang mondial
encore une fois si on compare avec la
Chine la Chine 79e rang donc il y a
encore de gros efforts à faire l'Inde
fait face à d'importants défis à court
terme inflation chômage des jeunes ou
encore des importants coût de sa facture
énergétique le tout dans le contexte du
défi climatique mondial qui touche
particulièrement le sous-continent
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités pour ce débat consacré à l'un de
Ingrid terrevad bonjour bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes spécialiste de
l'Inde journaliste docteur en sciences
politiques Christophe jaffolo bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi directeur de
recherche au CNRS et spécialiste de
l'Inde Jean-François Huchet bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur
d'économie spécialisé la Chine et
président de l'Institut national des
langues et civilisations orientale et
Mathieu croissanto est resté à mes côtés
rebonsoir Mathieu je vais je vais
commencer pardon mais en allant pour des
grands spécialistes comme vous vous
allez dire oh là là on est dans les
clichés mais je vais reprendre trois
mots qui reviennent peut-être le plus
souvent et je pense que ça ça sonnera
aux oreilles de nos téléspectateurs
quand on parle de l'Inde pauvreté cast
et démocratie je voudrais commencer par
là ingrid tervalt est-ce que l'extrême
pauvreté qu'on associe à l'Inde est-ce
que c'est toujours la réalité de ce pays
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile de
parler en termes absolu de l'Inde
à vrai dire il y a des il y a une classe
moyenne très importante qui représente
un marché d'ailleurs pour nos
entreprises
très très attirants et puis il y a aussi
des super riches le développement d'une
oligarchie en Inde ces dernières années
notamment qui s'est encore plus enrichi
enfin enrichi un rythme encore plus
effréné qu'avant donc il y a une extrême
richesse il y a une classe moyenne
importante et il y a aussi une de
beaucoup de beaucoup de pauvres
évidemment donc on peut pas associer
l'Inde aussi simplement que ça la
pauvreté Christophe jaffolo la les
castes la constitution de de l'Inde
interdit la discrimination liée fondée
sur les castes d'accord vraiment je suis
sur la base mais est-ce que c'est
toujours aussi important dans le dans la
structuration du pays ça reste très
important alors il y a d'ailleurs une
superposition quand même une coïncidence
quand même entre caste et classe et pour
en revenir pour pour redire un mot de la
pauvreté on a quand même eu en 2018 pour
la première fois de l'histoire de l'Inde
une augmentation de la part de la
population vivant sous le seuil de côté
ce qui est quand même le signe que la
pauvreté n'est pas derrière nous et
parmi les pauvres et bien vous retrouver
les castes les plus basses les castes
intouchables c'est en fait
l'intouchabilité qui est interdite qui
est banni dans la Constitution indienne
et elle continue à vivre sous le mode du
stigmate ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
des quartiers qui sont réservés aux
Intouchables dans les villages ça veut
dire de l'idée de l'impureté qui
continue à dominer beaucoup de relations
sociales et puis ça veut dire des
mariages qui continuent à être conclus
sur la base de la caste on dit que la
caste elle est particulièrement vivace
quand on parle de mariage et quand on
parle d'élection parce qu'on vote aussi
beaucoup en fonction de qui est candidat
de quel caste sont les candidats alors
ça va même la troisième question
Jean-François Huchet quand on dit l'Inde
la plus grande démocratie du monde
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est juste
comment elle fonctionne cette démocratie
je pense que ce serait plutôt cristaux
qui serait plutôt adapté mais moi je le
verrai plutôt au travers du prisme de la
Chine voilà si on compare
une vraie démocratie c'est-à-dire que
depuis le début des années 1950 vous
avez des élections vous avez une
séparation aussi des pouvoirs
exécutives judiciaire vous avez une
vraie société civile qui est très
dynamique et ça contraste
considérablement avec ce que nous
retrouvons en Chine qui est l'autre très
grand pays bien évidemment où les
libertés politiques n'existent pas et on
en a souvent parlé ici évidemment l'un
des tel en train en passe de de devenir
la nouvelle Chine voilà le l'angle de ce
débat un chiffre pour commencer la
croissance prévue pour cette année 2022
selon le Fond Monétaire International
6,8 % et les prévisions disent que le
Produit Intérieur Brut de l'Inde
dépassera celui du Japon et de montagne
d'ici 5 ans ça deviendra la troisième
puissance économique derrière les
États-Unis et la Chine Ingrid terre
verte est-ce que cette croissance elle
est en trompe l'oeil
alors là c'est assez plutôt à l'économie
à côté de moi que vous devriez adresser
la question alors allez-y Jean-François
comme vous voulez non je crois que la
Chine et l'un n'était à peu près au même
niveau au début des années 1980 et
aujourd'hui la différence est
considérable pas uniquement dans les
chiffres de PIB bruts ou que ce soit de
PIB par tête le PIB c'est pratiquement 6
fois aujourd'hui
le PIB de la Chine est six fois
supérieur trois fois en termes de PIB
par tête mais il faut bien voir que ça
se décline pratiquement sur tous les
indicateurs que vous allez pouvoir
rencontrer en termes de puissance
économique il y a
pratiquement 100 fois plus d'autoroute
construit en Chine quand même alors que
il y a un programme d'infrastructure qui
qui est dopé en ce moment par le
gouvernement maudit aujourd'hui
vous avez en termes de génération de
production électrique 5 fois plus de
de de de d'électricité installée en
Chine comparé à l'Inde donc vous pouvez
prendre pratiquement tous les
indicateurs et vous avez une Chine qui a
depuis maintenant 45 ans complètement
déclassé l'Inde sur toute une série ça
veut pas dire que l'un n'avance pas
est-ce qu'elle rattrape même si cet
écart est immense elle que vous ne
décrivez la question effectivement que
qu'on peut se poser il y a quand même un
eu beaucoup d'occasions ratées de la
part de l'Inde on va dire depuis 20 ans
parce que on attend l'un au détour avec
tous les problèmes qu'on rencontre en
Chine avec l'augmentation du niveau de
vie l'augmentation des des salaires et
puis plus récemment ce qui s'est passé
sur le covid et
l'incertitude géopolitique on demande en
fait à l'un de jouer un rôle aujourd'hui
vous voyez ce qui se passe avec la
fabrication des des téléphones chez
Apple on demande à l'un de jouer un rôle
que la Chine a joué il y a à peu près 25
ou 30 ans sauf que ce Grand Paris pour
l'industrie que maudit a lancé il y a
quelques années pour l'instant n'est pas
en mesure de fournir suffisamment
d'assurance auprès des investisseurs
étrangers pour dire voilà on va
véritablement partir de Chine pour venir
en Inde et produire en Inde et en plus
profiter sur sur de son grand marché
c'est une question de coût du travail
non
c'est une question qui n'est pas liée au
cours du travail c'est une question de
capacité à trouver aussi tous les
fournisseurs sur le plan local parce que
la Chine est capable de faire donc du
coup c'est pas uniquement le coût de
travail qui qui est qui est important et
puis très certainement aussi l'accueil
en matière de d'investissement étranger
il y a une bureaucratie qui n'est pas
aussi efficace en Inde comparé à celle
de la Chine même si la chinois démarrage
c'était compliqué mais il y a
aujourd'hui dans les provinces chinoises
une habitude depuis maintenant 20 ans ou
30 ans d'accueillir des investissements
directs étrangers et puis toute une
infrastructure locale qui s'est
construite et donc quand vous voulez
produire quelque chose en Chine et bien
vous dans un rayon de 500 km vous allez
trouver tous vos fournisseurs et ça
c'est un avantage comparatif qui est
considérable par rapport à ce qui existe
en âme alors vous évoquez l'ambition du
Premier ministre indien narendramodi
effectivement il est on est quelques
semaines après son son élection on est
le 15 août 2014 et voilà l'appel qui
lance finalement aux forces économiques
de son pays
allez vendre n'importe où dans le monde
mais produisez et manufacturé ici
nous avons des capacités du talent de la
discipline et la détermination pour
faire beaucoup
nous voulons offrir des opportunités
favorables au monde entier alors venez
et fabriqués en Inde
Christophe qui a manqué pourquoi ce pari
n'est pas réussi beaucoup de choses le
pari n'est pas du tout réussi
c'est-à-dire que on voit aujourd'hui la
part de l'industrie dans le PNB déclinée
et on est maintenant à 15% du PNB c'est
à dire qu'en fait on est au même niveau
que pour le secteur primaire le moteur
reste le tertiaire l'un n'arrive pas à
remplacer le it notamment les
technologies de l'information comme
moteur sont économie alors ce qui a
manqué c'est tout ce que Jean-François a
déjà cité plus les infrastructures qui
sont les ports les aéroports et surtout
les routes et les chemins de fer qui
permettent aussi la circulation des
matériaux et de la main d'oeuvre on ne
peut pas développer véritablement le
pays et quand même l'autre question
c'est l'adaptabilité de la main d'oeuvre
rurale à un travail de type industriel
ça ne s'invente pas passer du travail de
la terre au travail
de la de l'usine c'est quelque chose qui
se prépare et là l'un ne paye très cher
une sous-éducation qui va très loin on
n'a pas pris le temps d'alphabétiser
jusqu'à 1/3 de la population et donc on
a ce déficit par rapport au système
chinois qui a fait ce qu'il fallait en
termes d'éducation en terme de soins à
sa manière mais qu'il l'a fait et là on
n'est pas dans la même division l'un des
la Chine ne sont pas dans la même
division ce qui rend effectivement très
difficile ce que l'on appelait le déco
plane on allait découpler on allait
inviter les firmes qui ont investi en
Chine à réinvestir en Inde ça se passe
pour quelques cas particuliers qu'on a
déjà cité mais l'essentiel reste quand
même fidèle
à la Chine les Allemands qui ont
tellement invité investis en Chine non
pas du tout commencé à se réorienter
vers l'Inde par exemple c'est un cas
quand même assez emblématique et la
population je le disais en titre un
milliard 400 millions d'Indiens c'est le
prix c'est le chiffre qui est qui est
prévu pour l'année prochaine et le pays
deviendra le plus peuplé au monde est-ce
que ça c'est un atout ou au contraire un
un boulet dans dans l'ambition de du
pays à grignoter son retard sur la Chine
alors la démographie indienne a
longtemps été perçu comme un frein et
dans les années 2000 on a pensé que
ça serait l'inverse qu'il y aurait une
plus-value démographique puisque l'un
d'aller pouvoir compter sur malgré tout
un nombre important de jeunes éduqués
pour travailler dans le tertiaire et
comme le disait Christophe l'éducation
technique notamment n'a pas suivi on n'a
pas su on a su construire des
universités pour faire des pour former
des ingénieurs on a il y en a trop
d'ailleurs mais on n'a pas su construire
mettre en place des écoles pour pouvoir
mettre des techniciens donc finalement
cette dividende démographique on a même
si elle a existé en termes de population
on n'a pas su en profiter
voilà et d'ailleurs il y a une bonne
partie de la jeunesse indienne qui est
au chômage on le taux de chômage est
extrêmement important alors il est
difficilement quantifiable exactement
puisque la majeure partie des Indiens
travaille dans le secteur dit informel
c'est-à-dire l'économie grise qui n'est
pas officiellement enregistré et on sait
qu'il y a de très nombreux jeunes qui ne
trouvent pas de travail et qui n'ont pas
les formations adéquates pour pouvoir en
trouver donc la démographie là on voit
qu'elle a elle a des limites ça veut
dire qu'ils ont
Ikea des des plans de dénatalité en Inde
aujourd'hui dans certains états alors il
y a un ralentissement de cette
croissance démographique qui est pas
tellement liée à des plans venant de
l'État qui est c'est lié à ce que l'on
voit par tout ailleurs
l'embourgeoisement lorsque vous voulez
que votre descendance progresse en
termes sociaux au fait moins d'enfants
pour pouvoir les éduquer bon donc on a
un ralentissement mais on a quand même
encore 15 à 16 millions d'Indiens de
plus tous les ans
et donc il faut scolariser un nombre
toujours plus important d'enfants alors
que le budget de l'éducation reste à un
niveau abyssal on est à 6% du budget de
l'Inde donc là vous voyez le défi et ce
que disait Ingrid reflète aussi la
logique sociale on a fait des écoles
pour les ingénieurs qui viennent des
hautes on n'a pas fait d'école pour ceux
qui auraient pu passer par un travail
manuel valorisant valorisé parce que
justement ils ne sont pas au sommet de
la pyramide donc on revient au système
de casse dont on parlait des influences
qui vont jusque là sans aucun doute vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
Jean-François Huchet parce qu'on est en
train de d'essayer d'évaluer voilà les
freins à cette à cette croissance ou
éventuellement ce qui pourrait
l'accélérer la politique zéro covid de
la Chine à quel point ça amorce un
mouvement de désamour de certaines
multinationales pour la Chine vers l'un
est-ce que c'est tu as une phase de
journalistes ou est-ce qu'il y a quand
même un mouvement qui commence
non c'est pas un fantasme de journaliste
je crois que cette alternative indienne
elle est là présente dans les esprits
déjà depuis longtemps et je crois que
les déclarations de maudits sont là pour
le prouverne veut jouer une carte
en matière d'insertion dans dans
l'indivision internationale du travail
et d'ailleurs maudit a toujours
lorsqu'il était dirigé l'état du guzzara
qui lui s'inspirait beaucoup déjà de de
la Chine et ça d'ailleurs été au moment
de l'Ascension son ascension au pouvoir
il a utilisé pas mal de voilà de
recettes chinoises sur les zones
économiques spéciales qui avaient été
utilisé dans les années 80 en Chine
le problème c'est tout ce qu'on vient
d'évoquer c'est à dire que quand vous
mettez tout ça ensemble
les on va dire les industriels
occidentaux se posent vraiment la
question de savoir est-ce que on peut
investir durablement 20 ans longtemps
dans un pays
compte tenu tous les obstacles qui qui
existent et conviennent citer des
infrastructures la main d'oeuvre et
d'ailleurs il est intéressant d'observer
que une partie des multinationales ne
vienne pas en Inde mais parte plutôt au
Vietnam en Malaisie avec des difficultés
mais c'est plus je dirais
il garde leurs opérations en Chine mais
il y a plus une diversification si vous
voulez
et on réduit un petit peu la part de ce
qui existe en Chine mais la Chine reste
quand même l'endroit l'usine du monde et
je pense que ça va le rester encore
longtemps
sauf véritablement s'il y avait un
problème géopolitique majeur avec les
États-Unis bien sûr j'ai juste une
parenthèse parce qu'on a parlé du covid
en Chine et qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en 1 qu'est-ce
que ça a donné la gestion du covid en
Inde mais je crois que tout le monde se
souvient des images de délit notamment
qui était devenu un crématorium à ciel
ouvert ça a beaucoup choqué
frapper les esprits choquer les gens à
juste titre d'ailleurs le covid a été
quand même très mal géré les budgets de
la santé de budget de la santé n'est
vraiment pas très important il y a un
sous-investissement dans la santé
publique qui s'est vu il y a aussi une
façon de contrôler ou pas les
populations qui laissent franchement à
désirer
c'est-à-dire
qu'on a par exemple renvoyé beaucoup de
travailleurs migrants qui qui
travaillaient sur les chantiers qui
travaillaient dans les
comme domestique dans les familles de la
bourgeoisie
urbaine on les a renvoyés chez eux dans
leur villages du jour au lendemain
créant des mouvements de foule des
mouvements de panique
en plus créant des difficultés
financières en plus des difficultés
sanitaires donc c'était dramatique sur
sur le plan humain sur le plan social
sur le plan sanitaire ça montre d'une
part une impréparation totale et d'autre
part un manque de de respect pour les
gens et alors pourquoi parce que ces
gens qui se sont retrouvés sur la route
ils étaient de quelqu'un c'était de
quelle classe vous vous en doutez bien
il s'agissait d'ouvriers principalement
d'origine rurale et plutôt de baskas et
ils ont fait les frais les premiers d'un
manque de préparation et ensuite le
gouvernement a beaucoup joué sur la
carte médecine traditionnelle
méthode un peu
méthodes couées pour motiver les gens
alors maudit par exemple avait exhorté
la population à frapper dans des dans
des casseroles pour éloigner le covid
enfin on avait quand même des des
recettes tout à fait fantaisistes pas du
tout scientifique avec un discours un
scientifique ou anti scientifique limite
avec le recours à des méthodes
traditionnelles ou la superstition donc
voilà comment ça a été ça a été géré et
ça ça a beaucoup frappé évidemment les
esprits à l'étranger mais aussi en Inde
alors je referme cette parenthèse sur le
covid pour rester sur le l'intérêt des
des multinationales des grands groupes
internationaux pour
pour l'Inde cette
ces chiffres du cabinet d'études iwaï
75% de ces grandes entreprises mondiales
compte investir en Inde dans les cinq
prochaines années Christophe jaffolo ça
veut dire quand même que il y a
évidemment du business à faire bah oui
on parle de d'un milliard 400 millions
d'habitants ça c'est sûr mais pas
seulement non mais c'est ce
qu'effectivement on vous répondra à ce
que c'est un marché qu'on ne peut pas
ignorer c'est pas pour ça que c'est un
marché qui rapporte mais on se présente
où on se on se positionne plutôt en
espérant qu'il finira par décoller c'est
un cas assez fréquent tous les bonnes
consommations pratiquement son
concernées maintenant pour en revenir à
la question en Chine une chose qu'on n'a
pas encore dit c'est que l'Inde dépend
de la Chine au plan économique de façon
considérable nous dépendons beaucoup de
la Chine et on l'a vu dans la pharmacie
par exemple mais
la pharmacie Du Monde que l'Inde est
grâce à ses génériques dépend tout
autant des entrants qui viennent de
Chine et
et donc quand le covid a eu lieu et
qu'on a vu les principes actifs
s'arrêter de circuler et bien on a vu
nous aussi certains des médicaments
qu'on importe de l'Inde ne plus pouvoir
venir chez nous 126 milliards de dollars
c'est le défi c'est le moment c'est le
montant du code du commerce entre l'Inde
et la Chine la Chine et le partenaire
numéro 1 avec un déficit commercial qui
fait la moitié de ce chiffre tous les
ans plus grand le plus grand déficit
commercial donc c'est l'Inde qui est en
déficit commercial par rapport à la
Chine c'est bien comme tout le monde
juste pour être sûr d'avoir bien compris
d'ailleurs sur les marchés indiens sans
parler d'industrie pharmaceutique sur
les marchés indiens vous verrez des
biens chinois made in China absolument
partout mais partout ce qui montre bien
que la Chine est même pour l'Inde
l'usine mondiale de référence mais si je
reprends ce que vous disiez si un grand
groupe veut lancer un produit il le
lance aussi en Inde quoi c'est c'est une
évidence c'est exactement ce que disait
Christophe on ne quelle entreprise du
monde peut vouloir se priver d'un
sixième de l'humanité je crois aucune
aucune ne peut faire ce pari là ça reste
un pari ensuite on dit toujours de
l'Inde et depuis des décennies que c'est
un marché émergent ou que c'est un pays
émergent simplement un moment il
faudrait que ce pays et ce marché émerge
et on est toujours dans ce processus où
on doit voir à devenir la puissance
indienne infrastructure indienne le
dynamisme industriel et on n'y est pas
encore et il y a une de les nouvelles
qu'il faut aussi mettre en facteur c'est
le protectionnisme indien qui avait
beaucoup diminué à partir de 91 quand il
y a eu un tournant de type libéral on
voit le protectionnisme retrouver des
couleurs alors il est parfois non
tarifaire il est parfois masqué c'est
des normes très spéciales dans
lesquelles il faut rentrer il est aussi
très lié à un développement récent qui
est le développement d'une forme
d'oligarchie il y a des oligarques
indiens aujourd'hui le troisième homme
plus riches du monde est un Indien et il
était très très loin dans le classement
il y a seulement 20 ans il est porté par
le Premier ministre lui-même ces
oligarques il ne souhaite pas
nécessairement être concurrencé sur leur
terrain de chasse par des
multinationales occidentales et on a vu
vos daphones faire les frais du fait que
le numéro 1 de la téléphonie ne voulait
pas de concurrence sur son terrain de
jazz c'est une nouvelle donne qui mérite
d'être prise en compte parce que c'est
des risques nouveaux en termes
d'investissement étrangers et pour
compléter ce que dit Christophe jaffolo
la Chine essaye de vendre à l'Inde
depuis
bonne dizaine d'années voir peut-être
même 15 ans maintenant un accord de
libre-échange et ce sont le patronat
indien refuse systématiquement on a
constamment des campagnes
anti-chinoises
qui sont lancés par les entrepreneurs
indiens justement pour essayer de
repousser cette concurrence chinoise qui
arrive pratiquement sur tous les
produits mais le gros du déficit
commercial avec avec la chimie porte sur
les produits électroniques
électroménager voire même plastique
voire même textile la Chine exporte plus
de textiles vers l'Inde que l'un en
exporte vers vers la Chine parce que
l'inverse n'est pas vrai c'est à dire
que l'Inde la Chine est le premier
partenaire commercial de l'Inde avec
plus ou moins
au même niveau que les États-Unis par
contre pour la Chine l'Inde représente
très peu dans son commerce extérieur
donc on n'est pas du tout sur les mêmes
rapports de force
je voudrais qu'on parle de du risque
climatique dans puisqu'on est en train
de d'essayer d'évaluer les capacités de
l'économie indienne à progresser
peut-être à tenir les promesses dont on
parle depuis des décennies
ce risque climatique une grille servate
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il représente
notamment sur la question de l'eau je
pense que c'est une dimension qui est
très importante dans ce pays juste avant
de répondre à votre question sur le
changement climatique et l'eau sur
l'oligarchie vous me posiez l'action la
pauvreté pour qu'on puisse je vous avais
dit qu'il y avait aussi une oligarchie
effectivement et elle a des cette
oligarchie qui qui s'installe qui
s'enrichit un rythme effréné elle a des
conséquences effectivement sur les
partenariats possibles industriels etc
mais elle a aussi des conséquences
sociales et politiques très importantes
il s'agit pas de expliquer ou comprendre
tout ce qui concerne l'Inde au prisme de
la possible pénétration de ce marché par
des entreprises étrangères c'est bien
plus qu'un marché l'Inde c'est aussi une
société avec des gens et la présence
d'oligarques
si proche du pouvoir à des conséquences
sur la liberté d'expression sur les
médias qui sont complètement mis sous
tutelle ça a des conséquences sur des
tas d'autres choses que la signature de
contrat vous êtes quand même important
de le dire parce que sinon on a
l'impression que c'est juste un marché
sur la démocratie indienne dont on
parlait tout à l'heure voilà alors sur
le sur le risque climatique sur le
risque climatique effectivement l'un des
c'est alors le climat est un enjeu
majeur pour l'Inde comme pour tous les
pays mais l'Inde est un très gros
pollueur donc en effet
l'enjeu est très important et d'ailleurs
maudit s'empare toujours de cette
question la met souvent en avant
défend des des modes de de
des restos des sources d'énergie
durable plus durable et justement sur le
traitement de l'eau ou la France a des
entreprises de pointes l'Inde constitue
un marché très très important et
Veolia par exemple est très intéressant
par le marché indien depuis bien des
années et et ses partenariats sont voués
à ce à se développer et d'ailleurs voilà
vraiment maudit veut se positionner
comme un leader important sur le
changement climatique mais mais je vous
repose la même question parce que
notamment sur sur l'eau parce que vous
dites effectivement c'est une réalité et
d'ailleurs si le pays veut se développer
la question de la pollution liée aux
infrastructures qu'il faut construire
etc elle se pose mais bon c'est
peut-être un autre débat mais il est
aussi l'un des aussi en première ligne
sur les dérèglements climatiques et et
l'effet de ces dérèglements climatiques
sur sa capacité à développer son
économie c'est c'est une des parties de
l'équation bien sûr
ah vous avez plusieurs variables qui ont
beaucoup changé au cours des 15
dernières années d'abord le régime des
moussons qui est quand même draconien il
pleut une fois par an alors s'il ne
pleut pas d'une manière assez tendue
dans le temps et c'est de plus en plus
le cas les pluies sont violentes et très
concentrées elles ont des effets
ravinement et on peut pas faire pousser
les semences vous imaginez bien
deuxièmement vous avez des températures
excessivement extrêmement élevé au
printemps on est passé à 50 degrés dans
bien des états au mois d'avril dernier
c'était sans précédent et alors là c'est
justement ce qui grille en terre il y a
pas que les semences qui criait on
arrive à des limites même de la survie
humaine et puis vous avez le problème
des nappes phréatiques c'est-à-dire que
les nappes phréatiques
dans toute une partie de l'Inde du Nord
qui était rechargée par les pluies de
moussons et par les rivières venant de
l'Himalaya sont en baisse le penjabe par
exemple grenier Harry et à blé
d'ailleurs de l'Inde a maintenant un
énorme problème vous avez des puits qui
vont jusqu'à 200 m il faut aller 200
mètres plus loin plus profond pour
trouver de l'eau donc il va falloir
changer les cultures il faut arrêter la
canne à sucre il faut arrêter le coton
dans certains endroits c'est très
consommateur d'eau et il y a un dernier
problème qu'il faut garder en tête c'est
que l'Inde ces fleuves sont largement
alimentés par les glaciers himalayens
qui sont en train de fondre à une
vitesse très rapide et du coup vous avez
des grands fleuves comme le Gange ou
layamuna qui sont appelés à devenir des
Oued qui sont devenus qui sont appelés à
naître remplis que lorsqu'il pleut et on
les voit d'ailleurs ces fleuves en hors
des saisons de pluie ils sont devenus
l'ombre de même parce qu'ils ne sont
plus alimentés suffisamment dans
certains cas donc on a toute une série
limite de problèmes qui avec l'élévation
des eaux cinquième et dernière variable
à garder en tête parce que tous les
delta du Gange notamment
et du Brama poutre Bangladesh Inde tous
ces Delta vont être inondés donc on va
avoir des millions de personnes qui vont
devoir quitter les lieux où ils
cultivent pour trouver autre chose
ailleurs ça veut dire des migrants
climatiques en bien plus grand nombre ça
c'est le 21e siècle et il commence par
forcément en Inde on l'a vu ailleurs
déjà mais c'est aussi le Pakistan de
l'été qui vient de se passer on l'a vu
cet été
relation franco-indienne rapidement
aussi pour pour ajouter une dimension
importante c'était revenir par rapport
au Paris industriels qui a lancé maudit
vous avez par exemple par rapport à tout
ce que vient de dire Christophe sur
les carences en eau par exemple vous
avez des tas d'industrie qui peuvent pas
se développer l'automobile les circuits
intégrés enfin des industries justement
très modernes qui sont très
consommatrices en eau et en eau pure et
donc ça
complexifie considérablement aussi le
pari industriel que sur lequel maudit a
joué sa réputation aussi allez on parle
diplomatie tout de suite je propose à
Audrey
joindre rebonsoir aux doré on va on va
parler des faire le bilan un peu des
rencontres de ces derniers mois entre la
France et l'Inde oui alors Catherine
Colonna la ministre des Affaires
étrangères s'est rendues en Inde en
septembre c'était sa première visite
dans le pays Emmanuel Macron s'est
entretenu avec le Premier ministre
maudit en novembre lors d'un sommet en
Indonésie il faut dire que les dossiers
qui rapprochent les deux pays sont
nombreux alors on pense forcément aux
militaires la France et l'Inde multiplie
d'ailleurs les exercices conjoints
l'Inde qui est aussi un formidable
marché potentiel pour la vente de Rafale
d'ailleurs le pays vient d'annoncer que
de nouveaux exercices avaient été
concluant pour son armée ça pourrait
évidemment
de traduire par des contrats la France
qui est aussi un partenaire de choix de
l'Inde au sein de l'Organisation des
Nations Unies où elle plaide dans sa
faveur écouter Catherine Colonna nous
croirons régulièrement au Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies et je
rappelle que la France s'est mobilisée
continuera de se mobiliser pour
connaître obtiennent un siège de nombre
permanent au concept de sécurité parmi
les divergences les petits points de
friction entre les deux pays il y a
d'abord un gigantesque projet de
centrale nucléaire porté par EDF à 400
km de Bombay il patine depuis 13 ans et
manifestement il ne semble pas prêt
d'avancer autre point l'Inde
s'approvisionne en arme et en pétrole
auprès de la Russie elle a eu du mal à
condamner l'invasion en Ukraine Emmanuel
Macron a essayé de faire pression sur
l'Inde pour qu'elle fasse elle-même
pression sur la Russie pour l'instant
sans succès et puis je rappelle que l'un
de se situe donc en Asie Pacifique une
zone dans laquelle la France a de gros
enjeux St logique elle possède plusieurs
territoires la Réunion la
Nouvelle-Calédonie Tahiti est donc des
territoires maritimes et économiques et
ces derniers mois on l'a vu son
influence a été un peu mise à mal avec
la crise avec l'Australie sur les
contrats concernant les sous-marins
peut-être que cette relation avec l'Inde
peut-être qu'elle soigne ses liens avec
l'Inde dans ce contexte merci beaucoup
Audrey pour ce bilan rapide de des
relations récentes entre la France et
l'Inde Ingrid tervase je voudrais
revenir sur le la déclaration de
Katherine Colonna ce siège là au conseil
de de sécurité de l'ONU est-ce que c'est
un voilà c'est un objectif qui est
affiché qui aille la diplomatie indienne
tourne autour de ça ou alors est-ce que
voilà finalement c'est pas c'est pas
l'axe central de la diplomatie indienne
aujourd'hui je sais pas si c'est là que
ce central de la diplomatie indienne
mais c'est vrai que ça revient de façon
lancinante et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est ce qui se joue en tout
cas entre la France et l'Inde sur le
plan diplomatique c'est
qui se joue sur le plan stratégique
autour de la présence militaire
militaire et stratégique et des contrats
de défense parce que c'est vrai que l'un
des thés alliés de l'URSS pendant toute
la période soviétique acheter à l'URSS
des armes et qu'elle a chute de l'URSS
il a fallu diversifier un peu le panier
quoi il a fallu aller faire son shopping
ailleurs alors on est allé faire ce
shopping aux États-Unis en Israël et en
France voilà les trois grands alliés
stratégiques de l'Inde avec qui le pays
fait des exercices militaires dans tout
l'Océan Indien avec pour but d'affirmer
une présence mais aussi de montrer à la
Chine que que les États-Unis et la
France peuvent s'appuyer sur l'Inde
comme contrepoids contre-puissance
contre la Chine qui elle s'est implantée
au Pakistan et au Sri Lanka avec une
stratégie dite du collier de perles une
stratégie un peu d'encerclement de
l'Inde la France par ailleurs
tente de essai de vendre de plus de
matériel militaire possible à l'Inde se
souvient du cas des rafales
les Américains aussi vandalins des
appareils militaires et Israël des
technologies de surveillance notamment
et il y a beaucoup d'exercices conjoints
donc voilà ce qui se joue et voilà aussi
pourquoi l'Inde qui est resté allié de
la Russie sur le plan militaire ne peut
pas condamner ou ne veut pas condamner
aussi fermement que peut le faire la
France par exemple l'invasion de
l'Ukraine
il y a des enjeux effectivement autour
du des hydrocarbures russes qui explique
la la position diplomatique de l'Inde
depuis le début de du conflit en Ukraine
oui parce que l'un des très dépendantes
en matière d'importation d'hydrocarbures
et en particulier tout ce qui tourne
aussi autour du kérosène pas forcément
pour les avions mais aussi pour la
cuisine de tous les jours notamment dans
les dans les campagnes et
c'est vrai que
alors on n'a pas trop de détails sur ce
qui se passe actuellement il y aurait-il
des accords
en matière de
de prix sur l'achat d'hydrocarbures avec
avec la Russie mais on soupçonne ce qui
se passe aussi en Chine c'est-à-dire que
la Russie vend à des prix un peu moins
élevés qu'elles ne voudrait le faire sur
le marché international pour justement
continuer à conserver une certaine forme
d'influence aussi
vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis de l'Inde
Christophe jafrelot c'est effectivement
sur ces prix ces prix de des
hydrocarbures russes c'est quoi c'est
aussi une opportunité pour l'Inde en
fait d'un mal sort un bien entre
guillemets c'est à dire que l'Inde
maintenant importe un quart de son
pétrole de Russie c'est considérable
c'était 2% au tout début avant la guerre
donc on a effectivement une un effet
d'aubaine qui ne durera sans doute pas
mais l'un de résiste aux pression qui
alors pression qui sont parfois assez
hypocrites parce que nous sommes assez
contents que l'Inde ne vienne pas
prendre du pétrole ailleurs parce que
les cours parce qu'on avait fait que les
cours montrer donc on on est assis
hypocrite en la matière mais tout le
monde du coup il trouve son compte en
quelque sorte
allez-y dans la dépendance avec la
Russie elle est quand même très
intéressante parce que elle va au-delà
du militaire c'est-à-dire que l'un ne
prendra pas ses distances avec la Russie
quel que soit les pressions que nous
exercerons sur elle sauf si vraiment il
y a une agression chinoise et qu'il faut
tout de suite avoir un soutien
occidental massif mais la raison pour
laquelle l'un ne prendra pas si
facilement que ça c'est des sens avec la
Russie c'est que son idéal c'est un
monde multipolaire un monde où il y a le
maximum d'acteurs de poids le plus
comparable possible de manière à jouer
comme elle le fait très bien les uns
contre les autres et ne pas avoir à se
lier les mains avec des alliés l'un ne
veut pas d'aller elle veut des
partenaires sectoriels avec les
États-Unis on fait ça avec la France on
fait ceci avec la Chine on fait autre
chose mais on fait des choses avec tout
le monde et ça c'est une vision du monde
qui renvoie cette image un peu d'Empire
du milieu il faut que on s'adapte et non
pas qu'elle s'adapte aux autres c'est
clé dans la psychologie alors à quoi ça
ajoute avec le nouveau gouvernement ça
nous ramène à la démocratie le fait que
les valeurs libérales que défend
l'Occident ne sont pas sa tasse de thé
et que finalement avoir finalement dans
la Russie un contrepoids à l'ordre
international libéral
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on ne
vient pas s'ingérer dans la façon dont
on réprime ses propres minorités par
exemple pour ne prendre qu'un exemple et
ça c'est une autre raison pour
lesquelles la Russie pour laquelle la
Russie est plus durablement sans doute
qu'on ne l'espère en Occident un
partenaire de l'Inde et pas que de
l'Inde d'ailleurs le sud global comme on
dit vote plutôt Russie que États-Unis en
ce moment et c'est peut-être lié au même
question que celle qui travaille l'Inde
Mathieu la place de l'Inde dans la dans
la classe politique française qu'est-ce
qu'on peut en dire elle est inversement
proportionnelle à la taille du pays la
population franchement je suis sidéré je
suis sidéré parce que c'est un pays dont
on parle jamais jamais j'ai regardé ce
qui s'est dit pendant la campagne
électorale présidentielle très peu de
personnes en ont parlé il y en a une qui
en a parlé Marine Le Pen pour défendre
lors d'un discours de l'entre-deux-tours
à Avignon justement le fameux siège pour
l'Inde au Conseil de sécurité
une promesse en forme de cadeaux pour
pour narendramodi donc qu'elle est
l'idolâtre d'une certaine façon il faut
dire c'est cette fascination de de
l'ancienne président du Rassemblement
national pour maudit elle date pas
d'hier dès 2017 elle avait dit que voilà
il y avait des figures mondiales qui
l'inspirait pour dessiner une nouvelle
vision du monde Vladimir Poutine en
Russie Donald Trump aux États-Unis et
n'arrêter en Inde mais pour le reste
pour le reste c'est le vis-à-vis de
salle la dernière fois qu'on avait parlé
de l'Inde c'était en 2000 dans la
campagne présidentielle c'est en 2017
quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon faisait ses
hologrammes pour dire bah non mais il y
en a un qui a fait ça devant lui
regardez il s'appelle maudit j'ai un C
concernant vous prenez les discours
perdus on parle de la Chine on parle de
la Russie on parle des États-Unis ça
vous pouvez trouver des des traces de
ces pays-là dans dans toutes les
allocutions dans toutes les
interventions de tous les partis on a
même parlé du Venezuela bon voilà on se
sent paillettes sur le Venezuela est-ce
que c'était une dictature ou non mais de
l'Inde jamais
je peux vous donner une autre vision
mais qui est plutôt celle de peut-être
de la jeunesse française moi je suis
assez sidéré à l'INALCO puisque on
enseigne 103 langues du monde entier et
on voit un petit peu les différences
d'évolution et il y a un